aktuell sieht es allerdings sehr düster
aus vor allem für die Ruheständler in
unserem Land und 700.000 sind inzwischen
von der Grundsicherung angewiesen
Inflation und rasant Gestänge
Energiepreise setzen vielen hart zu und
wir sehen die Not täglich ich weiß nicht
wie es Ihnen geht aber ich sehe die nur
täglich wenn alte Leute Pfandflaschen
sammeln wenn
ältere Menschen in unserem Land an der
Tafel anstehen und nicht wissen wie sie
über Monat kommen und ich kann ihn ganz
ehrlich meine Gefühle dabei sagen ich
schäme mich ich finde es eine
bankroterklärung für unser Land ich
finde nicht dass ältere Menschen in
diesem Land Pfandflaschen sammeln
sollten sammeln müssen und vor allem ist
das ja nur die Spitze des Eisbergs die
Armut die wir sehen ist die Spitze denn
ganz viele Menschen sitzen zu Hause und
schämen sich und armut bedeutet auch
einfach oft zu Hause zu bleiben dort zu
hocken und eben nicht rauszugehen und
deswegen ist die erste Frage in der
Runde hier an Birgit Keller von mir aus
wie es ihr dabei geht und ob die Armut
sie auch mitnehmen wenn Sie sie sehen
und was sie meinen auf die Politik der
versagt ich habe sogar gesagt ist eine
bankrot Erklärung für unser Land ich
glaube dass es dass wir ganz viel
versteckte Armut in diesem Land haben
die wir gar nicht wahrnehmen ich habe
das vor vielen Jahren das erste Mal
wahrgenommen an der
Weihnachtsfeier unserer Schule in der
Grundschule da sollten Kinder in Wunsch
dran schreiben also anonym was ist ihr
Weihnachtswunsch und an der an der Tür
stand der Wunsch von einem Jungen
offensichtlich aus der Klasse meines
Kindes es wäre schön wenn sie an
Weihnachten wieder Strom hätten das war
eine normale bürgerliche Gegend das war
jetzt nicht irgendwie dass man sagt
irgendwie schwierige Gegend oder so wo
man es nicht vermutet hätte aber das ist
diese versteckte Armut glaube ich auch
von der wir reden in diesem Land
irgendwie das dass sich die Leute gar
nicht trauen so etwas zu sagen es ist in
peinlich und gerade Kinder leiden enorm
darunter weil es entstehen ja viele
Dinge dadurch von Mangelernährung bis
hin irgendwie dass sie nicht an
Bildungschancen teilnehmen an vielen
Dingen nicht weil es eben mit dieser
Scham auch verbunden ist dass man
darüber nicht redet und dadurch
natürlich auch sich vieles nicht
verändert weil die Kinder und
jugendarmut in unserem Landes ganz
schlimm die stabil geblieben was
also den letzten Jahren stabil hoch sie
haben damit vollkommen recht was ich
aber wirklich erschreckend deswegen habe
ich heute die älteren Menschen speziell
bei meiner These gewählt von 2018 bis
2021 ist die Armutsgefährdungsquote bei
Menschen über 65 von 14,7 auf 17,4%
angestiegen hier in Deutschland und da
ist natürlich meine Frage an Sie haben
Mordhorst wie das eigentlich sein kann
in einem Land wie Deutschland dass wir
nicht nur wirklich Armutsgefährdung bei
Rentnern bei Ruheständlern haben sondern
das ist ja auch noch steigt ja das ist
eine dramatische Beobachtung die wir
machen
ältere Menschen gehen in Rente und
leiden dann oft unter Steuern und
Abgaben viele von ihnen wollen übrigens
auch zusätzlich noch arbeiten gehen das
wird ihn im Moment politisch noch
erschwert wir wollen das dringend
erleichtern und deswegen dieser Zustand
der da ist der darf uns nicht
zufriedenstellen wir müssen den Trend
dringend ändern und die Richtung
wechseln es kann nicht sein dass immer
mehr Menschen in diesem Land
insbesondere ältere Menschen sie haben
gesagt bei der Kinder und jugendarmut da
gibt's ja auch eine Debatte über die
Kindersicherung
aber der bei den älteren der muss uns
erschrecken vor allem vor dem
Hintergrund des demografischen Wandels
was machen sie im Bundestag dagegen naja
wir haben das ein oder andere auf den
Weg gebracht jedes Jahr steigen die
Renten und zwar massiv im Osten noch
mehr als im Westen um das Ganze
anzugleichen erstmals wird es jetzt in
diesem Jahr angeglichen ich finde das
ist eine sehr sehr wichtige eine
wichtige Entscheidung die wir jedes Jahr
treffen aber ganz besonders entscheidend
ist ja bei Rentnerinnen und Rentnern das
sind Ansprüche die sie haben sind ist
eine Rentenversicherung bedeutet es wir
müssen Menschen dazu bringen dass sie
mehr einzahlen können dass Ihre
Ansprüche auch dadurch steigen also die
wirtschaftliche Produktivität Anreizen
und vielleicht auch das ein oder andere
Geschenk dass wir gemacht haben
sozialpolitische Wohltaten kritisch
hinterfragen insbesondere in den 10er
Jahren ist da viel gemacht worden
Menschen sind früher in Rente gegangen
es wurde viel umverteilt dass er kommt
uns jetzt gefeiert zu stehen gut man
muss ja hier sagen hier ist ja auch die
Energiewende mit Schuld die steigen
Energiepreise plus ich meine dass die
Preise für Paprika im letzten Jahr um
66% gestiegen ist da können wir nicht
sagen oder es tut uns Zeit für die
Rentner schade dass sie vorher nicht
genug verdient haben oder dass Ihre
Ansprüche hoch genug sind die Inflation
betrifft alle insbesondere die
Lebensmittelpreise beobachten wir
steigen ja weit über dem was die
Inflation insgesamt anzeigt und das
bedeutet wir müssen dringend ein
Programm für immer Angebot auf den Tisch
legen wir haben dazu Vorschläge gemacht
die Kernenergie wurde jetzt vor kurzem
abgeschaltet aus meiner Sicht ein
Riesenfehler der gemacht wurde dafür
gestimmt dass sie abgeschaltet wird wir
haben gegen einen CDU haben gegen einen
unions-oppositionsantrag gestimmt und
das werde ich auch weiterhin tun dafür
stimmt dafür stimmt Grüne und SPD
das heißt sie haben dagegen gestimmt
weil es von der CDU kam nicht weil sie
Überzeugung war in der Koalition nicht
durchsetzen konnten und meine
Überzeugung ist dafür dass rote und
grüne nicht bei der Linkspartei für
Vermögenssteuer für Erbschaft für ihre
Erbschaftssteuer für die sprechen der
Schuldenbremse Stimmen dafür und das
bedeutet Koalition stimmen wir mit den
ampelpartnern das ist manchmal schwierig
und wir werden unsere Überzeugung
weiterhin laut artikulieren aber das
bedeutet Koalition aber Abstimmung ist
doch dann sozusagen das was sie
tatsächlich tun also ich sagen es ist ja
schön wenn Sie hier sitzen und sagen ja
aber wir stehen dafür und dafür aber
dann wenn es drauf ankommt nämlich wenn
man abstimmt stimmen wir anders ab das
ist inkonsequent also wir sagen es
ändert sich ja auch nur dann etwas in
diesem Land wenn sie dann tatsächlich
auch das Rückgrat haben zu sagen ich
stehe mit meinem Namen und miteinander
Stimme für diese und jene Politik weil
sonst ist das äh ja ich will jetzt nicht
verlogen sagen aber es ist zumindest ja
aber es ist nicht ganz einfach mal zu
Ende er sagen wir wir hätten jetzt damit
gestimmt mit der Union und der AFD
hätten wir dann eine Mehrheit gehabt und
dann wäre das genau dann wäre das
entschieden worden dann hätten rot und
Grüne gesagt die Koalition ist vorbei
und was wäre dann passiert dann hätte es
entweder eine Koalition der
staatspolitischen Verantwortung von
Schwarz Rot gegeben oder es hätte
Neuwahlen gegeben aber dass wir wirklich
dabei substanziell etwas erreichen das
hätten wir auf keinen Fall garantieren
können und deswegen kann man sich freuen
wenn man seine eigene wenn man sich dann
selbst bestätigt fühlt aber es hat am
Ende konkret wenig erreicht sie das
nicht mit ich stelle mir jetzt vor ich
bin im Bundestag und es seine
namentliche Abstimmung also jetzt nicht
dass alle nur es ist ja keine nicht die
FDP als Partei gesagt wir sind dagegen
die CDU-Antrag wir sind dafür sein sie
sitzen da mit ihrem Namen mit ihrer und
stimmen ab und wissen dann ich muss aber
jetzt zustimmen weil ich will ja nicht
der Union zustimmen ich selber werde
aber bald wieder in der Talkshow sitzen
wie heute bei Frau Brockhaus und dann
sagen ja das mit der Energiewende das
muss sie doch selber und da würde ich
wirklich jetzt gerne mal nicht den
Politiker reden hören sondern sie als
Mensch reden hören ob nicht manchmal sie
Politik da auch so richtig abfuckt ja
manchmal ist es einfach nervig als
jemand Neues in der Politik er denkt man
schon manchmal oder kommt jetzt ein
Antrag ich finde den eigentlich gut ja
aber ich stimme jetzt dagegen auch aus
Überzeugung weil ich da Überzeugung wenn
wir brauchen eine stabile Mehrheit wir
haben ein Koalitionsvertrag wir sind
vertragstreu und das ist an manchmal ein
Zwiespalt aber den der war mir vorher
bekannt also es war mir klar dass es
darauf hinauslaufen wird auf solche
Themen und das ist ja ganz normal also
die Union wird jetzt noch zweieinhalb
Jahre was auch wie lange auch immer
Anträge stellen mit Sachen die
vielleicht dir gut finden und wenn wir
irgendwann in der Opposition sein
sollten was ich nicht hoffe dann werden
wir Anträge stellen wo die Union
ablehnen muss das gehört nun mal dazu
und wenn man im Ergebnis sagen kann okay
im Ergebnis ergibt es schon Sinn dann
kann man dann auch hinterscheiden dann
kann man da noch hinter stehen aber
keinen Sinn es gibt ja keinen Sinn im
Ergebnis weil es kommt ja nicht einmal
das Ergebnis raus dass sie sich wünschen
also welches selbst wenn Sie wie man so
schön sagt vom Ende herdenken kommt ja
das die falsche Abstimmung bei raus
nämlich sie kriegen sie kriegen ja gar
nicht den Inhalt den sie ja selber sagen
ich halte ihn für richtig und
möglicherweise ist diese ganze
Politikverdrossenheit die wir im Land
haben dass die Leute einfach gar keinen
Bock mehr haben auf Politik und zwar
egal bei welcher Partei weil es nämlich
genauso läuft dass die Leute das Gefühl
haben mir ist eh nur Kuhhandel und die
machen sowieso was sie wollen und wenn
Sie hier bei uns im waldkreis sind dann
sagen sie alle ja wir stehen ja hier für
hierfür und dann gehen sie in den
Bundestag nach Berlin zurück und stimmen
völlig anderes ab also dieser
Vertrauensverlust in die Politik kommt
ja genau aus diesem Handeln und das ist
auch nicht nur die FDP das ist bei allen
Parteien so aber vielleicht wäre es ja
mal irgendwie was völlig Neues wenn sie
tatsächlich sie sind ja nicht gewählt
für eine Partei sondern wir haben ja
tatsächlich eine Wahl für das Mandat das
heißt sie sind eigenverantwortlich dort
deswegen haben sie ja auch die
Möglichkeit
eigenverantwortlich abzustimmen nehmen
Sie es doch einfach mal war gerade als
junge Politiker wieso ordnen Sie sich in
diese Systeme grundsätzlich sagen also
ich bin schon der Meinung wir haben in
Deutschland ein Problem dass sagen wir
die Kompetenz und die macht immer mehr
in Richtung Exekutive rückt immer mehr
mich in Richtung Verhandler Regierung
Minister und das die das Parlament
zunehmend ich will nicht sagen
Erfüllungsgehilfe wird aber dass wir an
vielen Stellen noch Einfluss üben können
aber als erste Gewalt als direkt
gewähltes Parlament er sollte der
deutlich größer sein und ich kann mir
schon vorstellen dass auch darauf
Einfluss zu nehmen und in eine Richtung
zu entwickeln wo wir als Parlament mehr
bestimmen werden als Koalitionsverträge
die von Ministerin und Ministern und
Parteien abgearbeitet werden ich glaube
das wären Beitrag das ist auch eine
Herausforderung hat nicht nur Vorteile
aber es ist ich sehe es genauso also ich
Stimme auch nicht immer dann zu ich
stimme auch nicht immer hundertprozentig
über einen mit allem aber ich bin schon
der Auffassung wir könnten da schon mal
was verändern ja also ich finde sie
waren heute ehrlich jetzt viele ältere
Politiker die hier sitzen hatte ob es
gut ist wie sie abstimmt das sei jetzt
mal dahingestellt dafür
nee mal sehen wie sich das
weiterentwickeln jetzt können wir
natürlich zu Ihnen Herr Weber sie sind
Ökonom und meine Frage natürlich ist ähm
was können wir denn gegen Altersarmut in
unserem Land tun
wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten wenn man
Armut reduzieren will das eine ist der
Königsweg wir müssen nämlich über das
Leben zum Beispiel die
Arbeitsmarktintegration verbessern also
das ist ja das entscheidende wenn man
gegen Altersarmut vorgehen will und erst
im Alter anfängt dann kann man ja nur
noch korrigieren das ich sage nicht dass
das deswegen unnötig ist das korrigieren
aber über den lebensverlaufen Weg
zusehen dass wir wirklich eine solide
Arbeitsmarktintegration bekommen dass
wir darüber auch wirtschaftliche Stärke
generieren das ist ja auch genau mein
herzensthema heute dass wir das schaffen
jetzt mit unserer großen Arbeitskräfte
Knappheit haben in wirklich in die
Richtung zu kommen dass wir es dass wir
es hinbekommen die Leute in Arbeit
solide übers Leben hinweg reinzubekommen
und die zweite Funktion von Arbeitsmarkt
und Sozialpolitik ist aber auch dann
wenn es nötig ist und Menschen darauf
angewiesen sind die Teilhabe zu
garantieren das haben sie ja am Anfang
richtigerweise gesagt und dafür brauchen
wir dann eine Sozialpolitik die auch
dann wenn das Kind sozusagen schon in
den Brunnen gefallen ist die hinreichend
aktiv ist damit Menschen eben nicht
abschalten damit sie nicht aus dem
gesellschaftlichen Leben Ausscheiden nur
weil sie vielleicht im Leben Pech gehabt
haben und das ist auch ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Punkt wurden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
für Sie